hey Alice can we have a minute fine
uh homegirls death it got us uh we're
pretty butthurt about it
really you know we want to come in
tomorrow and just pluck away and do our
duty here but I don't know if I'm gonna
sound okay on the phones because I can't
you see he just needs a day to grieve
have a good cry we all just need a
probably a good pride just a day you
wanted about you you know I'm gonna come
probably these crimes to knows yeah okay
so if you guys weren't actually Alice
hey what's up it's awesome to be running
you here I was just out there
individually talking with everyone and
we all agreed the best way to
commemorate homegirls life and remember
her is by immediately forgetting her and
it's working all day tomorrow okay Adam
don't mess this up for me you know how I
am with girls I'm like a bull in a
vagina shop like it's not my fault
you're not a Rico suave dude okay is
enough okay I don't know what you guys
are up to and I certainly don't know
what butthurt means but guess what
death happens and it's real sad and
we're all still coming in to work
tomorrow yes good
should we not remember homegirl by at
least having some sort of service for
friends and co-workers and out-of-town
guests I don't need that oh yes that
would be very good okay fine tomorrow
after lunch you can have a thing thank
you
we don't need a thing thank you so much
this is not fair Alice no fair I'm
having the worst day out of everyone in
this entire office
Adam except Adam except maybe homegirls
you